Hello unto ye.
He's a bit spooked this glorious day.
Best I... stroke this big dick till he calms.
Almost there. There.
What a miraculous day the Lord hath made.
Let us be glad and rejoice. For he is inside all of us.
Noah, how are you now?
"Noah" worse off than the next guy, I suppose.
Daniel! I haven't seen ye in-
The age of a dog once. Yep.
Daryl.
What can we do for you?
Wayne, your community has always used us right.
Hopefully, you-
Feel as though we've used you right.
Once.
You've said it at least twice.
Twice once?
At least twice.
At least twice once
Eh- twice or more.
Not once or twice once?
At least twice.
Twice or more once?
Can confirm.
Wayne, you've been a great friend unto me for many years now.
Ok.
For banging the boxes summer last.
I feel the great need deep within me to repay you for
the kindness has shown the very best way I know how.
Oh, here we go.
Well, how's that?
With a sausage party.
Wait, first a box hammer and now-
A which?
A sausage party.
Well, he must mean literally.
I've spent the majority of mine adult life
stuffing my meat into casings.
It's thrilling work, rewarding and exhausting. Yet, I won't
rest until my sausage has touched the back of your throats.
Well, I do's love sausages.
Me too. Like I love it so much.
I'd feel a bit better if we could bring a date.
Ah.
I'm afraid there's only one rule of a sausage
party. No women allowed.
Okay, so he meant literally as well as figuratively.
Are your daughters going to be around?
Not today.
They're having a party with mine wife in our
very own kitchen.
That's a good thing.
Besides, a sausage party is a good chance for
men to blow...
Off a little steam.
Yeah, I'm not sure we can make it, Noah.
Darryl, you silly gosling, I haven't even
said when it is!
Right. Shoot.
It's today!
We'll be there.
I love sausages.
Me too. Like it's so good.
What goes on in a sausage party?
Well, Darryl, it sounds like it's a parties
where guys eat a lot of sausages.
Like, literally the sausages parties. But also it's
a dudes-only party, so figuratively, it's a
sausages at parties as wells.
Daniel, I must confess, you are testing the
limits of my one-room schoolhouse education.
with all those fancy words. I know that
Mennonites aren't exactly known for having a
wagon load of gray matter.
But fuck can they run...
Still, I do wish I could give mine children
great brain.
Alas, that's of no matter.
So what sayeth ye? I won't take "Noah" for an answer.
So no daughters?
No, not on this day.
What about sisters?
Daniel, time will tell.
By the looks of the sun, it's fast approaching noon.
It's 3 p.m..
I'd best get home to prepare.
It's as much for your benefit as mine.
For ye haven't truly lived until you've had
Dyck meat in your mouth.